Matt, Ben, you've
been here before.
You know the deal.
We're sending you
home to recreate
an iconic weapon from history.
However, there's a twist.
Of course.
You knew there would be.
Because you are both
"Forged in Fire" champions,
we have decided to bring back an
extremely challenging weapon--
the Scottish claymore.
Claymore!
Yay.
WIL: Enjoy.
This massive, two-handed
sword was wielded by Scottish
Highlanders as early as 1490.
Made famous in
modern pop culture
by the film "Braveheart," its
impressive size and length
made it a fearsome weapon.
The claymore is easily
recognizable by its quatrefoil,
crossguard, and angled arms.
Due to its large size,
the heavy sword was
usually swung with two hands.
It was so deadly it was
nicknamed the "slaughter-sword"
by the English who faced
it on the battlefield.
Because of its
prowess, the claymore
was a mainstay of the Scottish
Army for nearly two centuries.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
Good luck, man.
[music playing]
Today I plan to
get two billets
of Damascus welded
up, hopefully twisted,
maybe welded to each other.
It'll be a good day if I can get
all three of those things done.
The big forge just
wasn't working right.
It was coughing and spitting.
So I had to retire it
and just do everything
in the smaller forge.
It's tougher to work
with the smaller forge
because it's not as hot.
I'm five hours in.
I haven't even gotten
the metal to start
making the sword yet, so.
It's just one of those setbacks
that could really bite you.
Plan today-- first
thing is to profile it,
grind it, get that thing into
heat treat as fast as possible.
I just grind.
I'm grinding and
grinding and grinding,
and I'm trying to get
as much done as I can.
And then I run
into a major issue.
[bleep]
Ugh!
There is a little thin spot that
I didn't mean to put in there.
Just chasing it.
It's getting thinner
and thinner and thinner.
Just gonna have to go with
it, though, because it's
not flexing weird there.
It just looks weird.
But when you're under a
time crunch and you rush,
that's what happens.
Let's just say I made
that traditionally thin.
BEN: So it's the
beginning of day three.
I finally got the
blade drawn out
and ready for the heat treat.
This is the largest
quench I've ever done.
It's making me quite nervous.
I'm adding salt to make
sure it's the right height
when I put the sword in.
My major concern with
the quench today, I
have to watch for warping
and any kind of twisting.
You know, it's a
big, long blade.
A tiny little twist, and you
can almost corkscrew the thing.
So I just have to
be really careful.
[suspenseful music]
I'm very happy.
The quench seemed
to go really well.
Sword is still straight.
It's a good day.
MATT: So yesterday, I got
the sword rough assembled.
I got the handle core fit
and the guard roughed out.
I'm feeling pretty confident
I'm gonna get done,
and I am exhausted.
There's two ways to become
rich as a knifemaker,
start with a small fortune
and start with a large one.
And I'm not a rich person, so
$10,000 would definitely help.
[music playing]
That was me.
So I suck cutting with
a two-handed sword.
I think my sword is capable of
cutting much better than that.
We'll see what happens.
BEN: It's day five.
At the end of last
night, I was very,
very happy with my progress.
Pulling the sword out of
the etch for the first time
was one of my favorite parts.
I hose it down, and I get my
first glimpse of the pattern
that's in that blade.
Absolutely gorgeous.
And I've got a long list of
things that I need to do.
It's just time to get to work.
I kind of feel like
a surrogate mother.
I spent an entire
week making this thing
and putting my blood,
sweat, and tears into it.
But, uh, I think I
made something amazing.
Can't imagine what
would be in it.
Ben, Matt, welcome
to the gun range.
I'm thinking Ben is terrified
at the idea of somebody
shooting his sword.
I was the first time,
too, so I understand.
As you can see,
we've brought back
a test worthy of a champion's
blade, bullet splitting.
Each of your blades will
be locked into a vise that
will fire a single round at
your blades to test their edge
retention and strength.
Your weapons are strong, should
split the bullet no problem.
They're not strong, well, your
blade could shatter entirely.
Good luck.
Matt, you're up first.
3, 2, 1.
Engage.
[gunshot]
[bleep] yeah!
Nice.
[gunshot]
You got a couple little
dimples on the edge there.
It's just a little
bit dulled, but
everything held up beautifully.
Good job, Matt.
MATT: Thank you.
Ben, you're up.
Are you ready?
Sure.
Let's do it.
You got it, man.
J. NEILSON: Let's get it ready.
3, 2, 1.
Engage.
[gunshot]
MATT: Nice.
BEN: There we go.
Yeah, that sucker
just fragmented.
[gunshot]
Well, Ben, the only
problem I can see is, uh,
rubbed a little bit
of your etch off.
Did nothing at all to the blade.
Edge is still perfect.
BEN: Thank you.
Gentlemen, the Scottish
claymore, as you know,
was a brutal weapon
on the battlefield.
So to test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'm gonna take a single
blow through both
these front legs of the horse,
simulated with sugar cane.
If your blades are sharp, they
should pass right through.
Matt, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Kill the horse.
[dramatic music]
Matt, this weapon
is so amazingly light
and flexible, as well, that when
I hit, there was no resistance.
It literally passed
right through the legs.
I was through them
before I knew it.
Well done, Matt.
Really well done.
Ben, you ready?
Let's do it.
DAVID: All right.
Let's give it a try.
[dramatic music]
He's still down.
Yeah.
Well, Ben, it cut cleanly
through the first leg.
Kind of bogged down on the
second leg, unlike Matt's.
And I have a feeling it's
the width of the profile
up here just slowing
it down a bit.
But I don't think that
horse is running ever again.
Nicely done, Ben.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To see how lethal on your blades
are, I will take your claymore,
and I will try to cut
through these pig carcasses
with one chop.
As you know, last
season, both claymores
suffered catastrophic
failures on this very test.
Let's see how much lethal
damage your blades can do.
Matt, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Go for it.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
It didn't break.
That's a win.
Matt, I love the
feel of your blade.
It feels very
comfortable in the hands.
It's very easy to maneuver.
It was sharp enough
to cut through,
in terms of lacerating,
but it's just so flexible,
it didn't go through.
For this test, sir,
it will not kill.
I'm pissed at
that pig right now.
Ben, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Hope so.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[dramatic music]
[exhales]
Ben, this blade
just sliced all
the way through that carcass.
It's flexible.
It's got good feel to the cut.
This, sir, will kill.
Thanks.
DOUG: Good job, man.
Matt, Ben, welcome back.
The judges have
evaluated your weapons'
performance and construction.
It was difficult, but they've
made their final decision.
Gentlemen, both of your weapons
are bulletproof, they're sharp,
and they're deadly.
But today, there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion.
[dramatic music]
Ben, congratulations.
You are our first two-time
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Great job.
Matt, I have to ask
you to surrender
your Scottish claymore.
I'm a "Forged
in Fire" champion.
That's never gonna go away.
I don't feel like
I failed in this.
I don't feel like I'm a
loser in this or anything.
I just feel like Ben
did slightly better.
And that's awesome.
Ben, you are our first and
only two-time "Forged in Fire"
champion.
You will also be receiving
that check for $10,000.
Your claymore is a thing of
beauty, not only to look at,
but to wield.
[clapping]
- I'm at a loss for words.
- Thank you.
DOUG: Great job.
Oh, my God.
I am the "Forged in Fire"
champion of champions.
I can't believe it.
The people I was competing
against are so good.
To actually have come
out and win this thing,
it's absolutely amazing.
[music playing]